if you change your title or your
thumbnail does YouTube re-rank your
video does posting shorts hurt my
channel if you want subscribers if you
want views if you want monetization the
answer to all of that really is only
make better videos what is your advice
for small YouTube channels to grow right
now generally speaking what we've seen
across YouTube is that people who post
both long form and short form tend to
have higher engagement than people just
doing one or the other
on today's episode of the think media
podcast we are busting YouTube myths
with a YouTube employee Renee Ritchie
Renee doesn't just work at YouTube but
he also has 328 000 subscribers on his
own channel so it's time to lean in and
learn from this YouTube expert do yellow
icons impact search and discovery on
YouTube when ads become limited for some
reason or any number of reasons where
you've got green on monetization feels
you're like oh breath of fresh air but
if it turns yellow
is the distribution of the video
throttled down in that scenario so the
way that it works the best of my
understanding is that Discovery search
Discovery is not governed by ad-friendly
guidelines yellow icons or green icons
but it is still governed by Community
guidelines and oftentimes what I think
confuses people about this is that
separately ad-friendly guidelines will
determine this video is not safe for ads
and Community guidelines will determine
oh this is like like for example adult
content and if you're flagged as like
adult or mature content you wouldn't be
distributed to an all ages audience
because YouTube really is meant for 13
and up and we wouldn't want a situation
where like your 13 year old sits down on
a sofa and a bunch of adult videos or
mature videos pop up all over the home
screen for them so those videos are like
if you subscribe to it if you're
searching like that's sort of covered
with that but because they often happen
at the same time I think there is some
belief that the yellow icon triggers it
but really it's two systems responding
to similar signals if you change your
title or your thumbnail does YouTube
re-rank your video so now not exactly
that way but YouTube like the algorithm
tries to follow audience response so if
you change your thumbnail and your or
your title and the audience responds
better to it the algorithm will factor
that in when it comes to recommend
recommendations and it'll probably rank
higher like its distribution might go up
and it might and it'll probably rank
higher based on that audience uh
feedback so it's not a trigger in that
moment but what many people do in hour
one hour two hour three they perhaps
feel like their title or their thumbnail
could be resonating better they're like
I'm a seven out of ten I feel like this
should be like a three out of ten at
least they make a pivot there and since
you're maybe still in those early hours
it's the fact that audience Behavior has
changed in response maybe that drove
click through right up maybe even a more
accurate title
made people stick with it longer and
that pivot that you just made is
affecting rankings but it's not that it
changed and Google was like all right
I'm just going to re-rank you but it was
because audience Behavior shifted yeah
and I'm glad you said more accurate
because I think some people think oh I
just need to get them to click and
they'll make a more Sensational
thumbnail or more Sensational title but
then that will no longer like the video
will no longer deliver on the promise of
those things and people will start
abandoning it faster so you'll see CTR
go up but retention tank and then the
video will perform worse like but I
don't understand CTR is way up it's like
yes because you no longer are giving
them the video that matches the sort of
packaging you put on it does posting
shorts hurt my channel generally
speaking what we've seen across YouTube
is that people who post both long form
and short form tend to have higher
engagement than people just doing one or
the other obviously there's going to be
exceptions on both sides some will do
much much better some will not do better
maybe even worse but just broadly
speaking and because shorts tend to live
in the feed and long form tends to live
in the home on the home page there's not
that much overlap so you put up a new
you put up a new long form people are
going to be enjoying that in the home
page if you do a new short short time
after that people will be watching that
in the feed it's not going to conflict
with it on the home page does taking a
break from posting videos hurt my
channel many are worried I gotta keep up
one a week two a week but I'm tired or
family stuff's coming up and if I if I
stop for four weeks if I stop for two
months is it going to negatively affect
my channel yeah so it's a really good
question it's something that we think
about a lot as well because we do care
like desperately about the well-being of
creators and when we've looked at it we
haven't seen any sort of universal
negative impact broadly speaking it
hasn't made a difference across a wide
range of channels on YouTube again
they'll always be outliers like Corey
Kenshin shows up takes six months off
lens number one on trending every time
over and over again and there's probably
some people who you know maybe they take
some time off and a new like a new
personality shows up in their space and
just Wows a lot of people and captures a
lot of audience neither of those happen
a lot but there probably are some on
both sides I think it also depends again
on your personality some people see
their YouTube channel as like their
business it's like their mom and pop
restaurant or their mall kiosk like what
would you do if you had to take time off
from that and it might be that you plan
to have someone fill in for you or you
batch a bunch of content so that maybe
it's not going up the same page but you
still have a study steady stream of
content or maybe you you put up like you
schedule Community posts you do
something to keep engagement because you
just want to manage it you don't want to
leave anything to chance it feels better
for you you're more comfortable managing
it other people don't even want to look
at it they just like taking a vacation
I'm gone for a month I'm not even
looking at my channel I think Tom Scott
famously had guest hosts every month
every year when he took a month off so
it really depends like on what your
personal stress level is like and how
you want to handle it does an
underperforming video
hurt my channel if I have like one
really bad video should I be depressed
discouraged and should I give up no not
at all YouTube tends not to look at
individual creators and channels we tend
to look at videos and topics so just
because one video isn't the best
performing video even if it's a complete
dud it doesn't mean the next video isn't
gonna be the best video in the history
of YouTube and it would be bad for
everyone involved if we didn't give each
and every video a fair shot at like the
maximum potential it could possibly have
like imagine the baby squid right before
baby start baby shark hadn't performed
well baby shark would never have been
this huge video so just it it doesn't
really work that way but I also think
that sometimes we over index on
performance like on my channel I know an
iPhone review is going to do gangbusters
it's going to do really well and
accessibility or environmental or
educational video isn't but those are
really important topics and a really
important audience for me so sort of
like in Hollywood the big Blockbuster
movie gets the actor like big
Blockbuster box office and numbers they
can go do the Art House film The Big
videos sometimes gives me the
opportunity to do the smaller videos
that I really want to make I just go in
knowing they're not going to be like one
out of ten and I go in knowing they're
going to be 9 or 10 out of 10 but I
still think they're really important for
me to make does linking off platform
hurt my video performance YouTube allows
you to link to a approved website during
your end card but of course people Link
in their description maybe to their own
website to other social media platforms
perhaps to their book on Amazon or any
other number of things if perhaps they
even put a link in the pin comment does
that ultimately hurt my video
performance I think like the way to look
at that is is waiting so like some
people immediately put a card when the
video starts and go watch my other video
and they'll even say that like if you
missed this video go watch it and then
people are gonna leave like if people
are interested they're going to leave
your video like you chose to sacrifice
that video to send them somewhere else
and I've gone through this on my own
channel because I have sponsors in
almost every video and I always think
like so I always do the sponsor spot at
the end because I figure like they've
watched my video now they can just go if
they want to but that means I'm not
going to get them to watch a second one
of my videos and we know binging like
people watching like one or two or three
more is a great way to get into their
watch History which is a great way to
get into their recommendations and be
shown more of my videos I think all of
these are like choices so if you have a
link to another video top most like the
most attention pinned whatever you might
start getting up like build up that
session time build up that binging of
your content if you choose to make that
an affiliate link you you're sort of
sacrificing that binging but maybe
that's going to make you a ton of money
so these are all like I think like more
business decisions especially at the
Creator side do time stamps hurt or help
my videos timestamps AKA chapters AKA
time codes that are clickable and that
is that are they helpful or could they
ultimately hurt my performance metrics
on YouTube I think it's a bit of both
like I think we worry about them as
creators because we think people will
hop around and that'll hurt our total
watch time maybe cause a bunch of dips
in our in our retention but I think
they're also good for users like good
for viewers and where a viewer I think
this is boring I'm just gonna cancel out
of this video I'm gonna abandon it and
you see like retention just drop at that
point they might see the chapter and go
oh but this one looks really interesting
to me so instead of just leaving the
video they're now going to go and watch
a later section maybe they'll keep
watching from that point I think like
ultimately you want a video that
everyone watches every second of but
realistically there might be videos that
you make that have certain sections
appealing to certain people so I think
it's it's sort of like a trade-off
you're trading off the potential of them
jumping around for a reduced risk of
them abandoning is there a correlation
between
key moments when videos rank on Google
and the video has been kind of chopped
up in terms of a search term and being
found on Google and the metadata of time
stamps or chapters that are added on
YouTube I'm not sure
um I think for most people probably not
a huge deal anyway because external
traffic typically isn't like even if
like Google is 90 of your external
traffic external traffic is maybe two or
three percent of What discovery is so I
don't think it's like anything that
would move a needle but I also don't
know if Google's doing anything
different there than YouTube does and
you touched on this a little bit earlier
but to put it bluntly does posting time
really matter no I I mean there there
might be certain categories where it
does matter like like if you're doing
the stock market and like the opening
Bells at 9am and you know like you need
a video out by 9 30. like there might be
situations where your content is bound
to external time clocks but when when
we've looked at it for the majority of
videos If you're willing to wait like of
course if you put a video up in prime
time it's going to get more views faster
but over the course so and like that's
like for the first 24 to like 36 maybe
48 hours but if you look over the course
of two weeks to a month we've seen
almost no difference in how like where
videos end up in views depending on
where you what time you post them that
was technically our lightning round
mythbuster uh uh sequence of questions
but now going back into some topical
questions touching on hashtags
should I ever use hashtags in my titles
I think like you don't have to use
hashtag shorts for example anymore the
system is smart enough to know if it's
vertical or square and under a minute
it's a short but there might be times
where you think a topic is so much more
so much more gravity around it than you
do as a Creator or you do as like a like
an individual video that you want to tie
into it like maybe it's a coronation or
maybe it's like the World Cup and you
think there's just so much attention
that you want to show up on that tag
page that's basically what it does like
you click on that hashtag and you see
more videos around the same topic and
you think that there's so much interest
people are going to do that and you want
to show up there other times you might
think you know people I'm a big enough
Creator my videos are interesting enough
and I don't want to risk sending people
to a hashtag page I'd rather they watch
another one of my videos afterwards so
again it's one of those things you've
got to weigh the the risks and rewards
so personally using a hashtag in a title
is different than adding three hashtags
to the description which show up above
the title and are clickable would you
opt for adding them to the description
keeping the title clean with if you will
less chance of clicking away or is it a
case-by-case basis yeah I think like
it's it's more of a macro like do you
need hashtags to begin with I agree with
you they're cleaner not in the title if
you think that it's so important that
it's wicked obvious it's the most
important thing about the title then you
could do it but I would be more like
like what benefit do I get from
including the hashtags gotcha talking a
little bit about money how much does
YouTube keep and how much do creators
earn I read on Google's page that if you
turn on watch page ads YouTube will pay
them 55 of net revenues from ads
displayed I recently though did some
math and um this may have changed there
may be all kinds of different factors
essentially that YouTube that the
Creator gets 55 YouTube keeps 45 we saw
in between January and April this year
that actually YouTube had earned more
like 61 and we had earned 39 based off I
think our yeah our our RPM and I also
know that RPM gets a mixture of
different Revenue sources
um but kind of keeping it at a broad
level with the question is that just a
general rule and would that be perhaps
normal calculating and that I I was
calculating the difference between CPM
and RPM CPM being the Top Line money
collected for the channel over a period
of time and then RPM on that video
format for the period of time to be
clear this was just long form videos
what do you think that discrepancy is
and what maybe would be a way is
actually technically this mysterious or
is there anything that we can sort of
count on as creators I think like it's
not it shouldn't be mysterious and it
should be 55 I think like it's 55 of
monetizable views will always be like
some views that are claimed by a rights
holder for example like maybe not on
your channel but on some people's
Channel and there might just be like
just because there's in like there's a
slot on your video it might not have
gotten filled uh by an ad so like these
are just monetized bills monetizable
views that were actually filled by ad
inventory and then there's also like
de-spamming that goes on for example
like there's some level of spam views or
spam clicks or something like that that
might be happening and that could be
like discounted at a later date so I
think like if you look at when your
AdSense actually comes in that's
probably the cleanest version of it
because we try to give you data in real
time but because it's in real time it
will sometimes be updated like you might
sometimes see views for example going
like go down those views and it's just
that there was a bunch of spam accounts
or Bots that we removed from the system
and then their views disappeared with
them where their likes disappeared with
them where their ad clicks disappeared
with them so I would if like if if there
is any discrepancy I would first go and
just look at AdSense and see what your
your total was there I want to better
understand RPM and let me know if my
thinking is correct
there actually isn't technically a way
to measure we can see CPM that's going
to be the total amount of and it may be
a general number like you said you're
just feeding us kind of real-time data
but that is what a particular video or
Channel overall is earning the total
amount of money collected but of course
YouTube's from an Advertiser that wants
to advertise on videos YouTube takes
some the Creator gets some
um music's right rights holders may get
some all that whatever so then RPM is
the amount we actually keep however the
RPM metric could also be influenced by
Super Chat super stickers and the more
active those other monetization forms
are on a channel
perhaps the more diluted that number
could be if you were just trying to
figure out how much a video earns am I
is my thinking correct there I think so
I have to be candid with you that I'm
the worst when it comes to business like
I'm very bad at it I could I I I hired
like a business manager instead of an
editor because I know how to edit videos
I don't know how to do anything with
business so you're probably a much
better source of that kind of
information than I am gotcha and for
just for the record it would be uh
awesome in the future to even just have
more granular uh meaning how much my
videos earned that's kind of the
question would be like could I look at
YouTube separate from and regardless of
I'm just curious regardless of super
chats regardless of Channel memberships
regardless of anything else if there was
a way to break those things down that
may be there but that's just a personal
ask any features anytime let me know and
I'm happy to pass them on to the team a
little more Ninja question that came in
from Josh on Twitter
about ads if you just let YouTube do its
thing with ads so we just check the
boxes and if the video is longer than
say eight minutes in this case he's
saying if it's a 30 minute video I'm
letting YouTube manually place the ads
if I let them do that does YouTube Share
the content more is question number one
or does it matter in terms of search and
Discovery yeah the search and Discovery
system deliberately has no knowledge of
ads so it has no knowledge if you have
ads turned on turned off what kind of
ads because we didn't want that to be an
influence we want the the pure is the
wrong word but we want like
recommendations or search and Discovery
to be its own thing so whether you
monetize it or not and how you monetize
it has no effect on assertion Discovery
if a 30 minute video I let YouTube do
the ad placement and they placed five
ads in there or if I manually went in
and decided to place 10 ads on a 30
minute video will the viewers be shown
each of those ads no matter what I'm not
sure about that
um it might also depend on admin story
at the time whether all those slots can
be filled not something I have any
experience with but I also think like uh
just as a Creator I personally like to
manage the experience I gotta think
about it like from the audience what
make the audience happiest I think maybe
maybe it'll get maybe it is good maybe I
should go and look at it again but I
always think that I made the video I
want to design the ad experience the way
I'm designing the video and that is more
time consuming and cumbersome but it
just feels like that's my Creative
Vision so you recommend you personally
yes manually add them and I've seen an
hour-long video on your channel so you
might be thoughtful thinking just like a
Hulu show that there's going to be maybe
ad breaks that are relevant but you're
going to be choosing those yourself
manually yeah I don't have a
recommendation one way or another
because I'm not like I don't know enough
about it and maybe the maybe the
computer would beat me I'm not sure I
just feel like it's part of my artistic
Vision to put them in do you have any
tips for a creator that wants to
increase their CPM or RPM I mean I would
I would just like totally
non-facetiously say watch Channels like
yours I think like you have like there's
so many different categories and topics
and very very different RPMs and CPM
rates and maybe it's as simple as
picking like a topic that you're still
passionate about but has a much higher
CPM or RPM or maybe it's about
identifying times of the year where
people are more interested in
advertising against the topics that you
make like it's a it's a market like it
is a real Market where there's ups and
downs and changes and it is way beyond
anything that I can understand but
there's channels like yours that do a
really really good job of explaining all
that there's a new AI audio dubbing
feature coming can you give us a little
preview of what that is is it already
here and what could that mean for
creators yeah it's allowed it actually
was like a startup within Google and now
it's been brought over to the YouTube
side so they're in beta right now you
can go and sign up to get on the waiting
list for it and they're doing like a
couple languages of AI uh dubbing and
it's hopefully going to be built out to
the point where you have multiple
languages and it offers like a full
range of of dubbing Services I think
that's really interesting now because
we've seen like Mr Beast Jimmy has his
own dubbing service Creator Global and
there's a bunch of AI startups trying to
figure that out as well and it just
seems like a really interesting way to
his Point like 15 of the world maybe
speaks the language that your videos in
but if you do two or three or four
popular dubs maybe you start reaching
fifty percent if you do like five or six
maybe you reach 70 percent so it's just
one of those ways to make your videos
more accessible to more people in more
places so what is this called and how do
you sign up for the beta I think it's a
loud.com a-l-o-u-d but it might be dot
Google I'll double check what the link
is but or if you just Google like a loud
uh dubbing uh it's so it's it's still in
beta but it's a service anybody can sign
up for uh to be on the waiting list so
allowed a-l-o-u-d dubbing for everyone
allowed dot
area120.google.com we'll link up all
resources in the show notes of course
but excited for that do you think that
YouTube will add the ability to split
test thumbnails so it's something we've
said we're working on like I think we
started talking about it last year and
we talked about it again this year and
it's something that's really interesting
but we want to do it of course like in a
way that really benefits creators that
provides substantive value where you get
like a like a statistically signif
significant responses from it so I I
think Rick we're still working on it now
and I think the team is doing really
really interesting work and no timeline
for it yet but it's being asked like
it's being actively pursued I can't wait
for it is YouTube planning on doing
anything regarding spam comments uh one
of the big things I'm sure you're aware
of is a lot of soliciting typically of
crypto so they take your avatar they
take your channel name there's no check
mark and obviously is check mark
reserved for 100 000 subscribers yes so
to get a check mark to get verified on
YouTube you need 100 000 subscribers so
for a small creator of course the goal
here is they say hey WhatsApp us and
then they try to typically do something
regarding crypto I always know that your
role in YouTube employee roles in
general can get the hammer from creators
I can't even imagine the technological
implications of the platform the size of
YouTube but just kind of playing in the
middle
um I know that there was Graham Stefan
almost had his channel being threatened
of being deleted and had a countdown to
it or something that was not an action
of his own but something from people
thinking he was soliciting people for
money in all of the above what's
happening in regards to the fast-moving
world of spam comments and solicitation
at YouTube yeah so something that we
work on all the time is something I've
been involved in since I joined YouTube
because it's just it was it was
something I saw on my channel I wanted
to help as much as I could and I think
we started working on impersonation
scams that's when you would see that
WhatsApp or you'd see like uh telegram
me and it would be like on different
channels like you won an iPhone on like
a tech Channel or you want a car uh all
those sorts of things and I think we've
got a better handle on that now so if
you go to your settings and you turn on
stricter moderation I think you'll see a
like a good deal of that is no longer
present on my channel anecdotally I
think it's gotten rid of all of that
kind of comments like it's done a really
really good job we're always updating it
it's a game of cat and mouse so they
escalate and like we work on it and now
we've heard like there's other kinds of
spam that people are dealing with we're
paying much closer attention to that and
it's just it really is a back and forth
battle between highly highly motivated
cameras and and us trying to stop them
all the time what advice do you have for
creators who are frustrated by limited
advertising so I think it's one of those
things where and by no means like I
don't mean to sound callous about this
at all like I think about this deeply
and a lot like I I didn't have to deal
with that on my channel because it was
tech reviews it was like phone reviews
and laptop reviews and that comes
nowhere near advertising friendly
guidelines but it's also not something
that's really unique to YouTube it's
something that artists always have to
think about for example we used to have
explicit and clean versions of albums
because explicit versions couldn't get
radio play and if you decided to make an
explicit version maybe your fans loved
it or you felt like it was your artistic
voice but a lot of radio stations
wouldn't go near it and now you hear all
the time about Hollywood Studios and
movies and negotiating between like an R
rating and the dreaded NC-17 rating and
the PG rating and because that would
very that would like some some uh the
distribution could be greatly affected
or the amount of people that your video
gets shown to could be greatly affected
and I never want anybody to have to like
in a perfect world nobody would ever
have to choose between artistic vision
and and commerce that's sort of
historically always been the issue for
creators so if you have a huge video
coming up and it's really important to
you that you get every bit of money you
can from it maybe just like spend a few
minutes re-looking at the advertiser
friendly guidelines and say like do I
really need these curse words do I
really need to show this scene and
tailor it more for like that PG like
whatever the movie equivalent of that
audience would be like I want all ages
to see this I want the maximum exposure
and then tailor it for that sort of an
audience or if you're like you know this
isn't about money for me this is my
vision you know I need to say these
words I need to show these scenes then
just like realize that you've made that
choice as an artist and that maybe it's
not going to be as commercially viable
because it'll only be available for
adults or it'll like you might be
turning off some percentage of the
audience it just doesn't like curse
words in their videos or something so I
think like it's one of those things
where artists and commerce inside us
have to keep fighting it over is there
any
good place to get great data about
YouTube how like how many channels there
are also perhaps how many channels
are actually active have uploaded
recently or significantly how active
they are I love seeing letter from the
CEO or updates from YouTube that will
say channels that are over a million
subscribers is up 15 year over year
which is really cool and encouraging
information or but sometimes somewhat
vague understandably how many channels
are monetized the amount of monetized
channels and so I know that YouTube uh
does pass along information but I'm just
curious for you if there's anywhere you
look that maybe I don't know about or
people don't know about in terms of just
getting data about channels and YouTube
overall yeah I think there are like I
don't know of any like official sources
other than what you just said which is
like the letters from Neil now like the
CEO letters or sometimes like the
YouTube blog will be focusing on
something specific like that and they'll
be able to surface that information
otherwise I think there's some companies
that offer it I've no idea how accurate
or not they might be what is your advice
for small YouTube channels to grow right
now so I think like if growing is what
you want and it may not be like I think
there's a lot of people just assume
everyone's a girl on YouTube where some
people just really want to have their
like a place with their artistic Vision
but if you really want to grow I think
it really is about identifying like
three or four topics that you're
passionate about that you'll be able to
make hundreds of videos on for like
years and years and years because
nothing else matters if you just don't
want to make the content anymore and
then just be willing to try like test
those videos make a few of each see
which ones resonate with your audience
figure out which ones perform the best
and then go all in on them and start
packaging your content so that people
who watch one video there's always like
a fast follow video that they can watch
and you can get them to start binging it
so like I watch like they're finding my
channel through this video I'm gonna
direct them right to this video I'm
going to Deep dive them into this video
and get them watching in sets and the
more you can make it so that not only do
people love your videos but you always
give them more videos like that to love
it's almost like that Simpsons the same
but different every week analogy and
then the last bit is something I'm going
to completely steal from Jimmy and
Marquez Brownlee which is make better
videos and I think you see people like
spend a lot of time on metadata or a lot
of time but I'm very obscure analytics
because making better videos is hard
like it is soul crushing ego suppressing
work sometimes like you have to be
brutally honest with yourself and it's
easier to go mess around with SEO or to
go mess around with something else
because that has no like personal cost
to it but if there is nothing that that
making better videos like well if you
want subscribers if you want views if
you want monetization the answer to all
of that at the end of the day really is
only make better videos and for me it
was about consciously like looking at
every video making a list of what I
could do better and then work picking
one of those things and working on it
over and over again whether it was
lighting or storytelling or presence or
everything like that and until I got to
like diminishing returns and then
picking the next thing I think like like
people like you say that all the time
someone will say I'm not growing and
I've done everything you've said and you
go to their Channel and they've done
like one percent of what you said and
like they need better thumbnails and
like I had Jimmy once just open my
channel and say your thumbnails are
terrible your titles are terrible and
your videos are are boring like yes that
is true and even at his level he's like
I don't want to know why my videos are
good I want to know why they're terrible
because I can't fix good tell me
everything that's terrible about them
that gives me something to work with and
he still like is hungry enough that he
wants cares so much for making better
videos he wants your harshest criticism
on it I think that's like if you really
want to grow you have to sort of invest
in that you mentioned earlier how the
views that shorts are getting are
actually kind of more like Impressions
but you you kind of quoted that
even for newer channels YouTube will
perhaps give a new short or a new
channel a certain amount of views
Impressions to see how the content
performs and perhaps to see if it
satisfies viewers so along the lines of
the opportunity for small YouTube
channels What should creators know about
I think I heard Mr B say that YouTube is
still actually the most generous
algorithm on the internet
um and that channel starting right now
can grow from scratch you don't have to
oh it's only the channels that started
10 years ago and that have millions of
subscribers is there algorithmically
anything we should know opportunity wise
for a small Channel or a new channel
yeah so we do have a team that's job is
to try to like surface new channels like
sometimes I think you'll see like you'll
go to your homepage and you'll see like
a video from something you never heard
of and it has like like 23 or 300 views
like why am I oh that's actually kind of
interesting I want to see that that's
the sort of thing that we're doing we're
trying to work to find like really good
content from new and emerging channels
that we can Surface yeah we still think
you'll have a high likelihood of wanting
to watch there's nobody any good if we
surface videos that you're not going to
want to watch and you're going to ignore
but we want to find like those those new
those new videos that are going to be
enjoyable to you and give you the chance
to enjoy them and then hopefully that
helps those channels grow better and
faster as well that's encouraging that
you have a team dedicated serving small
channels and we certainly see in our
community channels starting from scratch
that are experiencing some big results
it definitely does come back though as
you mentioned making better videos and
I've noticed I watched a lot of YouTube
on my Smart TV and I have noticed being
recommended content from very small
creators all I'll be like that one I
like it like it gets my attention I
start checking them out and then I'm
also surprised that again it's not just
the big channels so that's incredibly
good news for small creators is search
based content still a big opportunity
for creators this year yeah I think in
general like if you don't know where to
start and you can optimize something for
a search it's a good way to get into
somebody's feed like you're going to
want to convert them into browse traffic
or suggested traffic so you're going to
want to have again like an easy follow
video you get them in through search and
you answer their main question but there
is like another part of that answer or
like a deeper dive or something that's
extra value to them that's going to get
them to watch that next video so I look
at it more like that's the that's a way
to open doors for your channel but
you're still going don't want to have
like a full home for them to walk
through once they get there what is the
worldwide opportunity for YouTube right
now I were recording both in the US here
right now we know that YouTube is a
massive opportunity like in 100
countries available in 80 languages but
from your Vantage Point what is kind of
the global growth Global opportunity on
YouTube I think it's just it's always
getting more exciting marching there's
always more creators I think shorts
short form video in general has lowered
the barrier of Entry like we used to
have me at the zoo and that was that's
basically a short like in today that
would be like look at me I'm just doing
something but then like the the like
getting into long form kept seeing like
it's just harder and harder and it's
like Marquez has robots and likes
there's like 400 cameras on this video
and it can seem daunting but with shorts
again everybody can just grab their
phone and go and make a video and some
of those videos perform ludicrously well
like just incredibly well and they can
then learn all the basic skills and then
not graduate but start making long-form
videos and off of what they've learned
from telling stories and like framing
things all of that so I think like the
opportunity now is just it's it's trite
to say it's bigger than ever but I think
especially like multi-language audio and
all of these new features podcasts it
really is just still growing Renee
you've been incredibly generous with
your time you took a lot of questions uh
I of course we've mentioned a couple
times that in the show notes people can
connect with you and everything but
shout out where people could follow you
what they can find I know there's a
couple different YouTube Creator
channels you've got the Critter liaison
one so what are all the different places
we should know to connect with you
um on the various things you're up to
sure so I'm at YouTube liaison on
Twitter and on YouTube and there's the
Creator Insider Channel we have a new
series of videos there interviews we had
Matt Helper and the head of community
guidelines talk about what policies like
on YouTube which I think people you were
talking about before would be fine
really interesting like how do how does
YouTube think about create and force
update policies we had Dave Rosenstein
talk about copyright and uh Creator
music Todd Beaupre was just on last week
and we talked about how the algorithm
works in a multi-format world and also
like how YouTube supports smaller
creators and a lot of the myth busting
shorts that we do are all up on there
and then the Creator liaison Channel I
just started a new series where I ask
creators for like one piece of advice so
like how do you I asked Eric how do you
blow up without spending money and I
asked Mr who's the boss how do you make
funner like more enjoyable videos and
they all give like really quick answers
based on their channels I love it well
Renee appreciate you so much thank you
for coming on the show and look forward
to connecting in the future thank you so
much it was so great being here so
thanks for checking out this episode of
the think media podcast reminder this is
actually part two of my conversation
with Renee so if you missed part one
definitely go back and listen to it and
if you enjoyed this episode and learned
something today please rate or review
the podcast on audio if you're watching
on YouTube smash like and let me know
one of your aha moments in the comments
section below and if you have any other
questions that were not answered because
we're definitely going to have Renee
back on the show in the future subscribe
so you never miss episode of the think
media podcast and I will connect with
you on the next episode